nothing can quite match what a
photograph can do unlike any other
medium unlike any other experience a
photograph reaches out and catches one
singular moment in time and space and
holds it there for us to look at taken
within a context and sequence of
infinite moments once taken a photograph
extrudes out of the perpetual movement
of time and stands completely for itself
one single frame when we were looking
through an old photo album or the photos
buried in the files on our computer or
on our phone and we see a photo of
ourself or a photo of a moment that we
were a part of we reflect on it we try
to recall what it was like to be in that
moment we might feel a strange form of
nostalgia that is almost palpable we
might miss it and longed to be back in
the moment that the photograph is
captured but perhaps when we experience
this it is not really the specific
moment in the photograph that we were
longing for but the moment in general
perhaps we were longing for what the
photo reminds us about right now what
the photo taunts us with how the photo
can so easily do what we want to do so
badly but rarely ever can a photograph
shows us what it's like to exist in one
frame of time to be completely present
to be able to see all the little details
in a given scene of our life to be
detached enough from ourself and the
constant happenings around us to see how
things might actually be how things
could actually be so with this I ask
what could they be right now if this
moment we're a photograph what would it
be would you look back at it sometime in
the future and miss it
would you wish you were back here would
you wish you could tell yourself to look
around and take in all the details to be
present in it and marvel at the scene
you are a part of allowing it to stand
for itself because with or without a
photograph every moment has its singular
frame and we don't always need a
photograph to feel what a photograph
makes us feel
thank you for watching if you found
enjoyment and value in this videos
please give it a thumbs up share your
thoughts in the comments below and if
you are not already be sure to subscribe
to our Channel we are constantly coming
out with new videos to help you
experience life with clarity and Wonder